[Music]
i think we've got to be serious for this
one
hi we're aunt and dick and this is
shocking answers for lad bye ball
so if you want to answer the question
answer the question if you say
pass you're going to get a shock okay if
you don't think i should answer the
question just shut up guys
i'm talking to my legal team
[Laughter]
if you switch genders for a day what's
the first thing you do
play with my boobs yeah it's got to be
in it you have to have a little feel
just to see what they were then probably
week three leave the house
yeah it would take a lot of fiddling
tassels
yeah why not yeah master that yeah
it would all be boob related it would
definitely be related yeah
brilliant tell us something
nobody knows about you
if you don't know it about me it's
probably because i don't want anybody to
know it
i'll take a shot
see how it releases there is the job i
know
who is the most famous person
in your phone michelle obama
shuts up
michael obama michael obama from ireland
michelle obama what can i say have you
got any uh alan carl
good one inaudible
[Laughter]
thank you george right so you're not
you're not taking a michelle obama
no because it's not true i don't put her
under that in my phone for security
reasons
what's under dave no she is dave the
driver she's under
she's under martin
bradley she
we could go on guys we're connected to a
lot of famous people
no more famous than michelle obama who
i'm not gonna bother now because she's a
very busy lady i think
actually it's an untrue answer so
because it's an untrue answer
ah
idiot stop it because you lied
that is that is shocking right
what is something you've done to try and
be cooler
oh it's good in it oh that is a good
question it's a good question
um i've tried to smoke to look hard
i've tried to
[Laughter]
you probably are a better answer have i
ever done anything to try and look
cooler
oh that kind of fascination with race
course when we were in biker grove and
we're like 4 15 40. and every
everything i wore i think you know what
make this better a whisk
and i went around his house and i stayed
over and walked in the pool
there was it there was a rail for waist
coat
for your waistcoat collection you're
gonna have to get shot yes
seven ways of showing
stop it what trial on i'm a celeb
scares you the most well the eating
trial eating
it's just disgusting why would you do it
what would be the worst dish
for you fish eye what's the point and
the worst thing about our celebrity for
us
is when we do the eating trial and one
of the rules is they've got to show
an empty mouth at the end and there was
that and you're like oh
there's still bits and you stink so yeah
i wouldn't be that one
what is your most disgusting habit
genuinely i don't think i have any
disgusting habits
i have a little bit of a nose pick every
now and again but don't we all we're in
the shower
sometime it's not a crime in it that's
not a crime though
is it a dirty album it's a habit if you
do it all the time i don't do it
all the time only when i need to pay one
whilst in the shower
who is your least favorite britain's got
talent winner
shock me please
stop it stop steer it on it's all i'll
put you in the face in a minute
a little bit my instinct needs to throw
a punch
i know you don't write the questions but
it it forces your album if you want to
punch a famous
person in the face who would you punch
as many people know i'm a lover not a
fighter
i'm not going to answer that i'm going
to take a shot
go home there it is
oh it's when it makes you ah there it is
ah there it is
it lasts a long time you're flipping
them
jeez whoa well we were ant and deck
and that was shocking answers for that
bye bye
idiot
you